this is FIFA 23.
it's insanely realistic thanks to
hypermotion a new technology that
captures animation from real football
matches using machine learning
to understand how far Thief animation
has come we've got to look back to where
it all started I'm can't show game
design director on the FIFA Team I'm
going to give you a quick breakdown of
how gameplay has evolved over the years
on FIFA
the first FIFA was released in 1993.
it's so funny to see this I used to play
this as a kid I love this game the big
innovation here is that it was the
isometric view an isometric view is an
angle that makes a 2d game look like
it's 3D
this was pretty revolutionary for the
time as other games showed a top-down
view side view or bird's eye view the
way they're running around and dribbling
this is not based on motion capture this
is based on an animator hand keying
individual frames of Animation this was
the same until 1997 when French football
player David genola acted out motion
capture for the game and that's when the
first polygonal or 3D virtual football
players were born and over the years
more polygon lines were added making the
players look more and more lifelike but
a few extra lines doesn't make a human
look well human so from FIFA 2000
designers sought to give players real
emotion and he made it look easy players
performed extravagant goal celebrations
and arguments with the referee but the
facial modeling was a work in progress
entered the PS2 a huge milestone for
FIFA 2001. and that gets us off the mark
nicely the hardware had about 10 times
the processing speed of the PS1 for the
first time animators could give players
unique phases David Beckham went from
looking like this guy to having a slight
resemblance and over the next 20 years
the animation kept improving still
filmed in EA's motion capture Studio
here we are at the start of the match
now as we move on to FIFA 2013 you see
some improvements there but actually the
animations are still a little bit rigid
because they've been captured in a
motion capture Studio environment where
it's not the most authentic real match
scenario so for FIFA 22 EA's motion
capture technology got a complete
overhaul
so high promotion is our groundbreaking
technology where we use these accent
suits to motion capture professional
footballers on the real pitch competing
so with traditional motion capture we're
in a studio space like this players will
be doing different moves like passing
shooting dribbling but it's more of a
scripted scenario whereas with the
accent suits players are outside playing
competitively in a real 90-minute match
of football we're not asking them to do
anything specific we're just saying go
out there play football and do your best
traditional mocap uses infrared cameras
that track reflective balls placed on
the outside of a suit worn by actors
it's kind of limiting and restricting
the xn suits track the motion of each
player internally which means there's no
need for several cameras or awkward
sensors getting in the way of play and
all of that data it's millions and
millions of data points those feed into
our machine learning algorithms and it
creates a much more authentic feel to
the game where everything looks way more
fluid from the way that the female
players move to goals dribbling and
sprinting so how does the machine
learning algorithm work so in this video
you can see how the machine learning
algorithm is detecting what is a jockey
a jockey is a skill move made by a
Defender the defender positions
themselves in between a striker and the
goal preventing the Striker from scoring
and the algorithm is able to distinguish
between a jockey and a Sprint for
example if I'm running and sprinting
that's not a jockey the machine learning
understands that so that's the first
part detecting what is a jockey motion
so it's got to be low to the ground it's
got to be crouched we take that data and
we feed it into the system so that it
understands like this jockey motion was
facing this way another one was moving
back but facing that way so all of those
permutations they're getting connected
by the algorithm when you actually play
the game it's outputting animations real
time that actually look like a real
professional footballer jockeying and
defending in that 1v1 situation
with high promotion 2 we've actually
added this acceleration feature that
allows players to have more nuanced
differences than we've ever had so for
example in Bape he's an explosive player
he gets off the mark right away nobody
can catch him however a player like
Virgil Van dijk he is also very fast but
it takes him a little bit longer to get
up to speed so we have different
archetypes for different players to sort
of mimic how they accelerate in real
life and when you get these sort of
nuances in the way players Sprint and
accelerate it just makes the game more
varied and less predictable another
change the dribbling animators have been
able to add way more personality this
time players can now turn way more
quickly to get past Defenders their feet
are actually planting on the ground
every step makes sense it's not like the
sliding that you saw in the previous
versions of the game so the game is
actually looking more like real football
than it ever has the animation team has
also made aesthetic changes to the game
see how the grass now flies of the pitch
as mbappe slides on the floor the
Shadows are also more exaggerated
creating a more cinematic feel the net
strings now Ripple when the ball hits
the back of the goal based on the 3D
geometry of a real net but as FIFA gets
more and more realistic where do
animators draw the line and how do they
approach The Uncanny Valley basically
that creepy feeling people get when a
fake human looks really realistic but
there's something still slightly off I
was actually an animator for multiple
years on FIFA The Uncanny Valley is
something that we're always looking at
we don't want to make the players so
ultra realistic that it's sort of
off-putting but the way we do that is we
stylize things we don't just make it
super realistic we make them a little
bit quicker to accelerate or when they
shoot the ball it's a little bit more
powerful so exaggeration is key in
making things feel right even though
they're not 100 realistic safety 53
developers captured a women's match for
the first time we first introduced
women's football in FIFA 16. that was a
big year the first time we've ever had
women playing in FIFA
when I look back at this footage it
looks good but I noticed that all the
Motions are actually based off men's
motion capture because that's what we
had done in FIFA for so many years now
as we get into FIFA 23 because we've
captured two women's professional teams
all that data is coming through and it's
feeding the women's game the women's
game looks so much more authentic
they're kicking properly they're
dribbling they're moving it looks
completely different than when you watch
the men's game we also have signature
run styles for the women's athletes some
of the star players like Sam Kerr you
can notice the way she's running here it
looks just like she does in real life
and not only her there's a few other
star female players that we have
signature star run sales for and what
other Industries could benefit from high
promotion the technology of using
accents suits and capturing outside of a
studio I think that will work really
well for like films and any other spaces
where you just want more natural
movement that's what we get with these
suits you're less restricted you can be
outdoors you can do what you need to do
to get that authentic motion that's what
it's about